welcome to seo foundations my name is
danny dover i am the author of the
best-selling book seo secrets i was the
lead seo at att it's also the lead seo
at a company called seomoz it's now
called moz and really i'm just a nerd
about this seo stuff
we're gonna talk about one of my
favorite things today so sit back grab
something you can take some notes with
and prepare to learn
today we're going to start our
exploration of seo foundations with a
very nerdy idea
the best way to understand a complex
field of knowledge like seo is to first
understand the incentives of the major
players so for seo this turns out to be
very easy the major players of seo are
users the humans around the world who
are using search engines every day
search engines themselves
and us the seos
so let's start with the most important
of these it's the users these are made
up of the hundreds of millions of people
just like yourselves who use search
engines like google every day these are
people in the united states they're
people abroad they're people using
english they're people all over the
place searching with text with images
with videos all kinds of stuff all of
these are considered the users and
they're what drive seo from the
perspective of search engine themselves
and from seos to people who practice the
profession
all right let's dive into the meat of
this the search engines themselves
search engines are technologies owned by
technology companies the most common one
of this of course is google google's a
company based on mountain view
california it's dominating the arena of
search right now and it has been for a
while but it's not the only player in
the game in fact there's a lot of other
important players the other ones that
are big in the united states are yahoo
which you've probably heard of because
it's been around for a long time
and bing which is owned by microsoft
outside the united states there's some
other search engines that are also very
important so first and foremost we have
badou which is enormous in
market share in china you also have
yandex which is gigantic in russia and
you have naver which is important in
south korea in addition to that you have
very specific search engines that do one
thing very very well so a great example
of this would be wolfram alpha which
works on computational knowledge and
complex mathematics
now the third major player in this is my
favorite now i'm very biased because i
am an seo and this is how i pay my bills
but i think this is the one that's most
exciting and the one that we're gonna be
talking about throughout this whole
course
so seo let's dive into that a little bit
it's an acronym and it's actually a very
confusing acronym because it means two
different things seo stands for search
engine optimization which is the field
and search engine optimizer which is the
profession so if you remember that part
you're good to go because that's the
trickiest part of this opening of this
opening section in that you have to have
one acronym that means two things
so what does an seo do
well an seo does a lot of things and
actually as we'll talk about it's an
increasing amount of roles but the
important thing to get out of this is
that an seo focuses on influencing
organic rankings in search engines so
they're not working on the paid side
they're working on everything else that
search engines like google provide
now that we know the major players in
seo let's look at what incentivizes them
by understanding their incentives you
understand what drives the market
so the first one that we have is users
now this is everybody yourself include
in this this is the world's population
who's using the internet to try to find
information
the incentive for the users of the
internet is to find the most relevant
information they possibly can on any
topic that they can at any time in any
language so it's a very very big goal
but something that search engines uh
work towards trying to solve so what
incentivizes the search engines exactly
well it's two things they're trying to
provide the most relevant results to
users worldwide but they're doing this
in two ways they're doing it through
organic results uh which they do not get
paid for they're things that they're
just going to provide so that they can
do a breath of information and there's
ads which third parties are paying for
that also have relevant information so
what is incentivized in the search
engines it's twofold they're trying to
attract a gigantic audience of users
with organic results and with the ads by
providing relevant information and it's
the money that they're getting paid for
with the ads
this works really really well for seos
seos are focusing only on the organic
side it's a completely different
profession working on the ppc side but
what's important for seos is to work on
getting their information or more often
their clients information to the top of
search engines so that their relevant
information is shown to the world's
audience of searchers